hey Ryan right hey [ __ ]
hi I'm Ryan Rea
and I'm Jerry well
two reasons to c.com where we give you
reasons to see and not to see Prometheus
want to hang out with us right consensus
there are a lots of reasons to watch
Prometheus there are a lot of reasons to
watch permit yes
I gotta take it down do you really have
fat one I don't think the people at home
are yeah Jerry's consensus yeah I think
there are a lot of reasons to watch
Prometheus there are a lot of reasons to
watch Prometheus especially in 3d I
gotta say the reason is see number one
Ridley Scott I was excited to see really
Scott doing this movie because it's like
finally he's back in a place where I'm
interested in seeing him cuz he's made a
lot of movies recently that I can sort
of take the leave but this was like cool
he's back in sci-fi you know this is
different from a lot of the sci-fi we
get today you know it's a look into a
different universe the designs are
different like it's a cool new sci-fi
world the way that it's realized and
imagine you really feel like you're
exploring a whole new world like you
believe in this new place there's a
certain real haunting menace to the
atmosphere of this film that I felt very
gravitated towards just the whole tone
of the film was awesome reason to see
number 2 cinematography
I especially loved the cinematography of
this film it's beautiful to look at the
technical design allow me to get pulled
into the haunting realm reason to see
number three visual effects an art
design this is just an awesome world the
whole design is just so goddamn stunning
it's worth watching on blu-ray just for
its effects I saw this movie in 3d
accidentally and you know I'm not big on
3d but this movie had kick-ass three
like him every 3d movie looked like this
I would be psyched it's just marvelous
to look at
I mean look at it oh hey Prometheus
every aspect of the design just made the
film look that much more real which
allowed me to get that much more pulled
into it reason to see number four make
up to die damn they make guy here's like
old dude just all technical aspects of
this film or superior reason to see
number five Michael Fassbender got
beautiful hair he does I never thought
for one minute this was just a guy
playing a robot you know he's a very
advanced Android who even though he's
not feeling emotion he understands it
you know he's fascinated by it it was
like watching a human who feels empty
who at the same time is so fascinated by
emotion and humanity in general simply
because he has them he managed to make a
very relatable character just very well
written Michael Watson better is just
rockin in man he's his god damn rock
rockin out with his [ __ ] out he's like
the prequel guy to go to you yeah I mean
he did x-men first class and now this
probably this and now the prequel to
shame
I saw shame that man has nothing to be
ashamed of it means Missy number six no
Mira pop new real rapist she has like
this great character descent into
madness I'm glad they didn't make her
exactly Ripley yeah from rippln Ripley
from alien really found you like believe
it or not guy now she really does do a
fantastic job in this film he could feel
a lot of courage behind the character
just with her performance and makes his
whole world that much more believable
for a swedish girl she does have a
beautiful Perdition accent no I actually
thought she was British until I checked
who she was to being a science fiction
movie she really seems to believe that
all this [ __ ] is really going on yeah
she sells the reality really well what's
going on like you believe everything
she's going through
you can feel an internal pain
or struggle for disappointment just how
[ __ ] up everything is for them it's
like they go there to find out all these
beautiful answers so then they were like
no you could really tell that she had
this whole character developed like she
felt like a complete person reason is
see number seven in his elbow dude he
was one of my favorites him in his crew
you know they really brought a lot of
life to the performance just every time
he was hot screen he was so [ __ ] fun
to watch
I love his character growth at the end
as well you never forget about him even
though he doesn't have that much of
screen time number one unanswered
questions
all these questions opening these so
called mysterious doors so much of why
is this avenue why are we here what's
going on what's the deal with it there
are so many questions that are such a
big part of the premise that just don't
ever get answered I personally find it
to be like especially disappointing
reasons not to see number two
disappointing ending the last like 15
minutes I was just so upset yes this
movie has like five Trinity's they go
there to learn why are we here
why are we this why did this happen so
the movie begins with we're gonna go
find out why then the setup for the
sequel is we're gonna go find out why
reason not to see number three
there are a few predictable reveals here
and there yeah I mean there's some
predictable reveals but what matters I
mean is the journey and the reveals you
know I got over those pretty quick
you